[Music]
so there there are many many games you
know even if you just google it actually
you can find some of the very most if
you just google if you're interested you
see say Google like the best or most
famous games there is a list actually
and you can start with one two and you
know the famous games you will see and
this is one of them this is a game
played in 1958 in USSR Sochi and this is
the game between polo guy have ski and
Nash made Dino's Rasheed Nash Medina
were very strong tactical players and he
has a lot of nice wins so this is one of
them actually against polo guy FC d4
Knight f6 c4 d6 block basically it's not
showing what opening he is gonna play
here it could be many different openings
so Knight c3 if he plays g6 then we are
in a Kings Indian defense but now he
plays a five so this is called what what
you know it doesn't have any specific
name but what's the the structure you
get yes all D in the end you know that
that type of position he for he takes d4
I prefer to play the move Knight f3 to
be honest with you I wouldn't allow IDI
yes Alex well I think what he wants to
do maybe if you play Knight f3 he wants
to maybe play the movie force and do
something like this perhaps it's
playable I mean this is not a common
line so I'm not very familiar with it
but I think it's playable 92 again you
just play Bishop f5 it's it's playable
so we have now efore played
I'm not a big fan of this move but let's
see it takes the reason I'm not because
temples now black is developing gaining
temple so now I played them
Queen d2 why do you think polygraph is
solid ask is such a strong player play
the move Queen d2 it looks kind of odd
right to block the bishop but what is
the idea what is the purpose behind this
what is he gonna try to do later on you
think well I don't think you want to
keep moving the Queen there right so how
do you think he's gonna try to solve the
problem of that bishop in the long run
Arjuna absolutely he wants to play b3 at
some point and put the bishop on b2 and
that way his queen is already developed
he can put a rock behind it okay so he's
trying to save a move by doing that g6
is played perfect Arjuna b3 there should
be seven
there should be two at least this way it
doesn't look he lost you know temple
obviously right so Castle Bishop d3 now
polygraphs key wants to put his Knight
maybe only two and Castle Knight g4
immediately you see Nash Medina we know
going for the strong attack here trying
to pressure again this game is played in
1958 so it's quite possible if you
analyze this game and sit with a very
strong engine
you might refute this play but again
1958 there and have the the program's
the engines the databases it was just
books magazines that's what they were
using to study so I would suggest not
look when you're looking at this old
games not to use the engine too much
because it will take the fun out of it
you can basically you know refute we
refute at least maybe half of the games
you know if not more if you sit there
and try to refute this ideas so 9g to
play Queen h4 I'm not sure if Knight G 2
is the best night have to seems a little
bit more solid to play here to cover
some more squares sewn IG to Queen h4
putting pressure on f2 you cannot cancel
because you will simply get mated
so he played 93 protecting against the
threat of night xf2 but it does looks
bit awkward near this 92 93 so I think
this nigt move I don't like it
what he did not GE 5 another possibility
could have been Knight ce-5 here put
some pressure now he castles f5 you know
in this kind of positions f5 is a
typical idea to try to open up your roof
and try to threaten f4 this is a very
important idea to remember f5 with idea
f4 f3
Bishop h6 Bishop on g7 is place well but
Nash Medina wants to bring the bishop to
another active square and he wants to
use the h6 Square to do that attacking
the Queen Queen d1 is played now what do
you think is the next move here f4 f4
attacking the knight nine goes back to e
to g5 when you lock the position with f4
the next logical thing to do is to play
g5 and g4 to put pressure so now
threatening g4 95 activating the night
and putting pressure on c7 now
I took yes
he decided that there is no time to
waste here you know of course Rukh f7
could have been played very well just to
protect upon and maybe try to attack
later but he thought the timing is more
important so he went for g4 and that
could be the reason why we have this
game now because of this g3 meeting g4
with g3 attacking the Queen
take take Queen h3 block really wants to
play the move Knight f3 check and try to
create serious mating chances f4 and now
in this position if you play Knight f3
check you can simply play the move I
think you're looking f3 Queen h2 chicken
somehow he is not getting made it here
but if y doesn't get made it
positionally he's doing really well here
like you know rook h1 Rukh h6 you will
drop your Bishop so
so it maybe should be six because if you
capture here he can now play Bishop
takes d5 takes d5 and do you see the
winning move yes check can I go to the
light squares checkmate
so Bishop e6 he played Bishop to c2 and
now
Oh keV seven
protecting this and also bringing more
pieces into the game when you are
attacking and you don't see immediate
breakthrough you try to look around to
see if you have a piece then you can try
to develop you can bring a piece that is
not developed and develop it so don't
you bring the undeveloped piece in kink
af to check if the King was only one we
have Knight f3 check so we have to go
here only move Bishop d5 eliminating the
night the night is active and is a good
defender so I just eliminated C takes d5
now what did he play here night before
right the knight is under attack you
don't want to lose a knight
so you just activate it and putting
pressure rope h1 and now
you really want to do something to drive
the skin yes rube takes that for now if
he takes he actually took so let's try
to understand if you take what the night
just queen g3 wins taking here if you
take with the pawn check then you have
this checkin will pick it up pick it up
and just basically the king is just
gonna get mated here in the middle so
that's why he decided let me take the
queen at least if he survives he knows
he will win but no surviving here
continue absolutely but still there is
no mate
c5 I think he just doesn't impose on no
okay which Knight specify
okay I don't know somehow he's not
getting made it I think at least it's
not force maybe there was just some
difficult made here but so that's why
and if you take with the other night or
John he just goes King c6 okay so that's
why he brought to be that's why he
brought the bishop in because now you
can use your night for discovery checks
so a for covering the be v square and
now
see five check
now the king cannot go back so it cannot
go anywhere he has to take it
BC ninety takes again he will go King to
c4 so I prefer to take with the pawn and
now the threat is see if I made see
so he goes B should be three trying to
create the escape route you know on c3
Knight III check King c4 well I guess
yeah you could have just taken on b2 but
then it takes on before ya take rook do
you one that's you're probably winning
after Luke check or bishop if I you're
winning there like this line is winning
cartoon check check
you know he goes somewhere you're
winning but you're not winning bye mate
you know so like he protects it okay
it's not a mate you're winning though so
d5 take take like that kick is coming
here now
first mate you have now
I know well you have something simpler
you have two moves mate you have a to
move made here in fact your look f6 if I
take Queen D three then I cover the a
six square okay 96 checking minute and
if he goes King ace he can't go anywhere
here he has to go here and now checkmate
alright so that is the famous game polo
guy have skin - Matti no we're gonna go
back this is 34 moves or the whole game
okay beautifully see he dropped drove
the King from g1 all the way to a6 to do
the checkmate from g1 all the way to a
six so that's the famous game that you
need to know okay famous game polo guy F
ski Nash met enough all right I have a
couple of more positions for you to work
on today to make sure that you're seeing
the board very well so let's start out
with this position here to play white to
play checkmate in three how are you
gonna do this you have to calculate
Arjun he'll the whole thing Bravo let's
go
King this six Arjun starts with okay how
many legal moves blackheads let's try to
understand three that's one correct
that's tube
why not take our June still mate
everybody still may don't do this okay
King see five perfect and if the night
goes anywhere you've got the mate and if
he goes here ooh June 95 check
you still have two moves to mate right
you still have two moves to go
the night is annoying peace yet too many
squares to jump too many too many
squares to jump to too many squares to
go to so what do we do with the night
yes take it
he still has a square to go to right and
if it goes here now what do we do Bravo
Bravo excellent that is a mate okay
excellent next
so everybody understand this puzzle so
you start with King d6 if he goes King
here you just take that's mate if he
goes here
you play the move Knight king c5 if he
moves anywhere it's made and if he move
goes to b6 then you have the ideal
position to do between before mate got
it
perfect next position see these are
mating tryst but they're not obvious you
know they're not like check checkmate
they're not that that kind these are
much harder ones no it's actually mating
net endgame so this one you just need to
find a net okay it might be a little bit
longer than three moves but just find it
the way to win like a net that it's
mating three but this is just a net this
one
then I'll have some more meeting oh yeah
since I already have this let's just try
to find a mating net here and then we'll
go back to a couple of checkmate in
trees aha
look before you mean correct yeah you
start out with them move rook before
now he plays the move a five because he
cannot move the night or anything so a
five now
again you don't want to allow him to
come here so you have to control it with
king f7
now if rook d7 you just go Bishop e7
then you have an IG seven mate so he has
to play Bishop g2 and now who is going
to show me the checkmate in three here
one two three
Arjuna excellent continue that's it you
see that
so that's setting Cup you know setting
up the mating net here so it was it's
equal material not so easy to me but you
setting up their ideas okay and mate you
just have to set it up okay
the idea of Route before all right
you're going to go back to those tricky
mating trees okay are you ready white to
play mate in three it's quite hard
actually normally you cannot really mate
if your roots are close to each other
like that right
so you have to have one be careful
Archer so you have to have one rook
cutting from further down and one roof
checking so you have to have that right
balance okay
so how you can do that
yes and he will block you from a three
and a five so that's the trick he is
gonna go 94 and that night is just
superbly placed there superbly placed
well yeah but that's the problem is we
need to do this in in three yeah I think
that first of all it's more or less
natural I think you're probably looking
at the first no that's a more or less
natural but the continuation is trickier
arjo what's the first move you think
yeah
rugby it is the first move because when
you play rugby eight now you're
threatening checkmate from here and
sorry checkmate from here checkmate from
here and that leaves you only with one
move to stop those checkmates and that
is 94 right that is the only move to
play because if you check on it I have
95 if you check here I have 93
what do you do now this is the hard move
here right here this is the hard move
after this move you're gonna realize
that everything is gonna work out for
you by that one move its heart let's see
so we know the first move but we have to
find the second move to make this work
otherwise it's not gonna it's not gonna
work you're gonna be able to win this
obviously but not in three moves yeah we
have two moves left now well you will
you mean here that's before
well yeah you will win the night but we
want to make this position in two moves
now did that idea wins the night here
okay but now the one move left now it's
not I made it was here
over we're here here takes the rock it's
gotta be something trickier yeah it's
not just the check check check check
would be easier and with these positions
you know you have to find a difficult
move at some point this is that moment
where you need to find that difficult
move to win it specified then you have
two moves to go you have to be specific
here Luke 8 to be seven he's suggesting
all right now the pan cannot move that
means he has to move the king or the
night
now let's observe all the moves if King
a three what do you do mate
correct if he moves here mate so now we
know the king moves are mated Knight has
eight different squares to go to here so
if it goes this direction then it
doesn't really matter you just go okay
won or rookie seven it gets trickier if
it goes this way
correct if it goes this direction
yeah symmetry symmetry yeah again you
see that same symmetry work see if it
goes here checkmate
and now the same symmetry works Bravo
correct good job then so let's do this
again let's do this from the beginning
go goes here you pass the turn you pass
the turn you improve the rook and pass
the turn and now it's funny if it's you
if it's your move here you don't have a
checkmate it's gotta be here smoke here
to have a checkmate so it goes here
checkmate
alright so that's a really hard one very
nice ok the tricky part here his King is
in the middle of the board and we know
that it's a lot harder to checkmate the
King when it's in the middle of the
board but here you have a way you're
going to be able to do this white to
play mate in three and in this one
they're not so many lines actually there
are not so many lines here in this one
so let's see if you can find a mate in
three idea here
and sometimes you know the way you would
solve these positions you have to find
like the the odd-looking move or at
least that's the solution you know it's
it's the odd idea sometimes we'll do it
but I have to say this is a really hard
one harder than the previous ones you
did because this one idea the move
actually here is the hard one because it
doesn't make really sense this move
unless you go deeper and then you will
discover the idea the six
you can find a lot of mating force then
but you need to mate in three that's the
trick you want mate interest not mating
for certain
you have to find the mate in three here
our tune
Queen g6 okay King 1/4 that's Tour
d'Argent
can you find you're still gonna have a
mate I think ah yeah you're right you're
right
yes buddy yeah he will he will run back
yeah so that's good thinking right there
are two but unfortunately he asking f3
yeah but since now you know this idea
now you have to try to work something
similar well your night will occupy two
important square and your king and queen
can control the remaining squares and
you will play a checkmate
so the knight has to control the squares
so that means your final move is gonna
be with the Queen right because you're
not even with the one who will be
covering the squares where where you
think we can go here guys 98 he says but
do you see the follow up door 98 Knight
moves in the side right
mm-hmm
whatever that takes that really takes to
me was one two three if you do this
route stuff
I don't know that takes like a lot of
moves
well let's let's I want to give you a
little hints the night I ate Archer kink
here do you really have to be around
tonight or maybe that night could be
that key guy who will control those
important squares look at that look at
that the night is on the rim bar is
controlling two very important squares
now he's got a couple of squares he goes
to can you control those two squares
with leaving everything the way it is
then king D for control right so we have
this under control we have everything
under control here so there's only one
square he can go to he cannot go
anywhere else than here and now that is
a checkmate
excellent Arjun I ta ta remember
sometimes you put the knight on the
corner and that's the winning move here
ninety-eight you see that yes yeah look
at that
every squirt is take a knight is doing a
great job controlling it yeah but don't
do this in a tournament ya don't like
only in a specific position so okay
let's start off again what's the first
move
Knight a8 he can't go here he can't go
here he can't go any of this square so
he has to go here yeah everything is
square guarded everything is occupied
and now Queen d5 checkmate okay so
another very nice way of checkmating
okay and the last one okay all right
white to play checkmate in three again
you have to make not the easiest move
here to win it okay
right - playmate entry again you wrapper
your upper rook there's no question
about winning it but the question is can
you win three moves
obviously the knight is our the problem
piece right the way it's set up there
it's not really helping us so which
piece we need to improve them the night
right but we don't have a good square to
improve now here I mean we can go to f7
doesn't help he goes king h4 right so
what can you do instead to perhaps get a
good square for him yeah but the idea is
correct you don't want to move the rook
rook is okay there it's cutting the king
of a sixth year but then you just cost
Knight f3
he could go night of seven when he goes
tonight f3 or something can you get him
king f4 yeah but then he takes tonight
you need to make a move that when it
takes the night you have a mate I know
you wanted to put a knight on f5 the
idea is correct but you have to improve
that idea
Arjuna yes now if it takes your knight
what do you have checkmate
so King f6 let's look at all the other
options if he moves the King now check I
got the mate if he goes here
you got the mate so he has to try to
move the knight to here let's say and
now we bring the Knight to f5 and now
any movie plays rook g5 or rook takes g5
is I made any move Knight moves anywhere
d4 d5 anywhere rook g5 is a mate
he's in the net so and if he plays
Knight so Knight iPhone is same thing
you play 95 and if he goes here check
the rook takes our June excellent he
goes here Bravo all right excellent
great job everybody
thank you for attending and see you next
time okay
[Music]
you
[Music]